like have you completed you completed
the witcher 3 wild homs have you played
any of blood and wine at all no not
button wine i played through hearts of
stone yeah beat the witcher 3 bass game
yes and hearts of stone was a super good
expansion pack but sort of a fraction of
the content in comparison to what's
coming out of blood and why it seems
jake how much did you play so we played
about three hours of the expansion and
there's supposedly twenty to thirty oh
wow i think like if you don't want to do
all of the if you don't do all the side
stuff and all the exploration then i'll
probably take around 20 hours just to do
the main quest but they said yeah you
can you can take thirty hours on this
thing i'll probably take more mm-hmm
just because i've so invested in that
world but yeah it sounds like a good
chunk of content she's CD Projekt of
like a problem well it has a problem
he's beating the game three times at
least and one was on that death march
and i think he's playing it again right
now completed witcher 3 three times yeah
cuz witcher 3 you got to do it three
times right work have you played Final
Fantasy 15 yes okay then you very much
are an expert of all things which ring I
guess the first question I'd ask is this
new worlds that they've built how big is
it and how does it look and feel is it
is it very different or is it just like
a reskin or headed a field to eat it
feels substantive so it I think it's
very different so you know how like
temerian sort of the northern realms are
very war-torn and you know that lots of
people were like taking sides and
battling it out this one is sort of
untouched by wars they've said multiple
times so when you're wandering around
you don't really see like battlefields
you won't see people sort of displace
from their homes it seems it's got a
much lighter air to it but from what we
played there is dark things brewing okay
into song but yeah as for sighs it's
about it's about the size of no-man's
land okay so it's a good size should be
plenty to do and obviously hearts of
stone was sort of A's single-player
quest within the normal world of The
Witcher 3 and which did have some side
quests as well and bits and bobs when
you get out into this world obviously
there is a main quest but is it sort of
littered with question marks around
place as well for random side quests and
encounters and stuff yes so we actually
had when Rob and I played on the map we
had all of those already like marked
okay so when you look at it yeah there's
I think in the factory they send us
there's like 90 new quests oh right so
there's plenty of quests I mean I don't
know how long they'll be the pro vary in
length but um it sounds like there's
gonna be plenty to do lots of locations
I think there's 40 locations too from
what I read yeah pretty cool um so what
else is different in terms of gameplay I
know you've added a bunch of armor and
whatnot yeah anything substantive in
that respect like yes so I mean the
armor is big I know they're gonna add
more Witcher sets I think the two
biggest things I took away from it was
the new mutagens I think they said
there's around 12 new mutagens and these
aren't just like perks you know how in
the main game you kind of had you know
you choose perks thing you assign them
to a slot and you can only assign around
12
but these aren't these aren't like
passive skills these are very aggressive
skills from what I saw like they showed
us one they showed us a variation of art
where Geralt would have like a huge
blast radius and enemies random would
freeze all right and they even told us
like yeah these are pretty overpowered
like this is something you're gonna do
later in the game and you can tear
through enemies with this stuff pull
over into regular Witcher do you think
so that's something I'm not entirely
sure about like I don't know if you have
to get the expansion in order to in
order in order to use all these mutagens
it's hard to say
they are also revamping the UI too so
this kind of falls in place with the
with the new character screen or you can
assign new mutagens is it's all redone
so it looks nice and clean I mean this
is the final chapter in the story of
Galit of Rivia you have to imagine maybe
I mean you do you actually one more
point you have to Clara do you have to
complete the first game to have done
this or does it work like hearts of
stone where you can sort of like boot in
if you don't have a high level character
or how does that work yeah so if you if
you haven't been to Witcher 3 or well
you should beat the witch with you if
you haven't beaten the area you can just
start a game right at the beginning of
it so similar what you could do in
hearts of stone yeah so you can start
right into it with Gerald that's already
Elina got equipment and he's leveled up
to a certain extent otherwise I think
you need to be level 35
whether or not you have to beat the game
or not they were kind of unclear about
that but it sounds like you don't have
to but I'm pretty sure you need to be
sort of nearing the end I mean probably
for spoilers stuff they might want to
you might want to have complete at the
end I remember that in hearts of stone
that there was sort of certain nods to
late-game stuff maybe not end stuff with
like late-game stuff that they spoiled a
bit so yeah it's similar with this I
mean I even found something I won't say
exactly what it was but it was
definitely referencing something that
took place near the end I actually found
it in the developer was there was like
oh I don't actually think you're
supposed to find that and that's really
this demo but yeah they go you side
first Mike yeah definitely
I mean after playing hearts of stone and
getting a little bit of a taste of like
a new expansion and what they were
trying to do with telling these
incidental side stories that didn't
really affect the overarching plot or
actually they did they introduced kind
of a big villain I guess and I'm not
sure if he'll be in Toussaint but that I
loved like Point Lookout and fallout 3
because I actually gave me a new world
Explorer and I'm looking forward to Far
Harbor which actually now that I think
of it if like the rumored release dates
are true for both are they gonna be near
each other
oh really yeah because they actually
have a release date for this right may
31st and far harbors not too far off
right let me look because if those are
both like simultaneous that's gonna
force a pretty tough decision that's
like a full RPG right there we guys for
May 19th
yeah I'm what is it blood and wine I'm
really excited for because I I loved
witcher 3 i played through it i played
through like another half of a
playthrough i don't feel the need to go
back to it right now yeah having a new
area to explore and like he had said the
whole idea of like peacetime kind of and
seeing how the war invades this area as
opposed to seeing the aftermath is
really appealing to me i love that kinda
reminds me of like there was a very sort
of british isles feel to means Skellig
is literally an irish word and like
scott a scots gaelic word and then like
the rest of it sort of felt a little bit
like england and you had the sort of the
rich people of the south of england
living in novigrad and the poor people
from the north living in the south this
kind of feels like the mediterranean
abyss where they're all a little bit
pump pump us and sort of yeah well to do
and stuff like that yeah i mean you
figure cuz there's no war there a lot of
them are very focused on you know luxury
and you know wine is huge in this so you
know Geralt gets his own vineyard
apparently really yes so they showed us
a little bit of that but yeah so you
complete a mission and you get a key and
you can go there in the panel you can
upgrade it and make some sick wine like
a home base and dye your clothes to be
great that's what you do and there's no
war you for sure
I hope there's another getting drunk in
your house seemed like the great one
from that there were Jews three that's
awesome so I guess you know you're a big
fan of the series final point on this
after playing three hours of it were you
what was your expectation going into it
and how did you sort of feel as a fan of
the series once you'd walked out of that
room so I pretty much felt that CD
Projekt RED delivered on almost
everything that I was hoping for at
least from what I played there was a new
character who's from the book which had
me really excited cool it was kind of
curious where he had been in this whole
lore but he shows up from which book
he's from he's from the second and third
okay I've only read the first three and
then the short story so I'm not entirely
sure don't my only real concern though
is the last expansion we didn't really
see Tris yennefer ciri dandelion and i
was like alright that's fine it's kind
of a side story but this one if we don't
see them I'm going to be I'm gonna be
pretty bummed because I've spent so much
time with those characters and can be
weird not to see Syria or yen but it's
CD Projekt RED I have a feeling we'll
see them but my poke their heads in
somewhere in any case it'll be the final
time we see Geralt of Rivia for a little
while but then again guess we can't be
too sad because then that means they're
working on cyberpunk 2077 so and other
games look forward to yeah wonderful to
see I mean that was the fantastic
surprise of last year that that game was
as good as it was and it's wonderful to
have more expansion packs coming out it
is out May 24 no 31st 31st the week
after
fallout 4 Harbor and over what an
overwatch which is those are a week
after doom and that's a week May 31st a
week before Mirror's Edge really I'm a
better where we are a few weeks maybe
yeah so if you haven't been already you
might want to start saving your shekels
because there's a bunch of big video
games coming in beating the games you
haven't been yes exactly and being the
game yeah I have to do the office that I
played on next
one for like a hundred and fifty odd
hours and uh now I for which your throat
and like now I in that time I built a
new PC so like I couldn't cross bring to
save over anything which is really
annoying with so wait do you have to
play like sixty hours of Witcher through
no or you get to I mean I probably I
have a character leveled up for hearts
of stone like one I pre-built one
although you're probably okay it's that
same level recommendation so you should
be okay good to know
alright let's stop talking about what
your people just talking about in each
other